biju miss me lad hamdulillah Salaam
alaikum peace be unto you thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Dean
show and this week on the Dean show
before the youth get wild and for the
ship sails we want to make sure that
we're doing the right thing at home
raising our children the proper way so
we don't lose our children because it's
a jungle out there so our next guest
Sheikh Yassin here from the UK in Dallas
so we'll see how is UK accent with the
dallas cowboy accent how this all fits
in we're going to meet him we come back
here and the d shop this is 13 the biju
this is the things the theme
this is the thing you know this is the
thing is the theme jus this is the this
is the this is please be on to you
Salaam alaikum walaikum salam ala the
law how are y'all doing I'm the left
fine did you pick up on the Texas accent
here and why are you in dallas not yet
you still got that nice British accent
oh yeah masha'Allah how are you doing
how did that break yourself how long you
been in the States here I've been dead
for six years born in born UK in the UK
how's the transition then it's been
pretty peaceful mm-hmm as opposed to the
hustle and bustle life of London the
busy life choosing a suburb / see it's
pretty peaceful and hamdullah a lot sent
me to the right community have a good
team people are work with good community
how many things have been going from
strength to strength so the time is
short just brief introduction about
yourself you memorized the verbatim word
of God you've been studying his deen for
a long time you've been telling us
continue from there oh I was born and
raised in England spirits of an Indian
region and started memorizing the Quran
from a very young age and after
memorizing the Quran I enrolled at
islamic seminary to study islamic
sciences after graduating from there i
went on to complete my masters in
islamic studies at University of London
whilst also serving as an imam at a
local mosque in London in 2006 I made
the big move across the pond and came to
the United States of America upon the
advice of Imam useful for another great
senior imam of dallas and ever since
then I've been serving as an imam here
now how did you overcome will you shield
it will you protect it I mean as a youth
growing up in London you got some wild
things going on people God will hard
over there drugs alcohol games gaming
all sorts of things that are away from
the organic way of living we want to
live
pure life a good life a life that's
pleasing to the crater that happens in
error now you went in the good direction
but many they don't make it that far
what kind of pressures were you under
that you overcame so the youth they can
kind of relate to say you know what if
he could do it I can do it too I was
quite fortunate because my parents are
always guided towards Islam and
hamdullah you know all praises to Allah
and you know the upbringing from the
home is very important my father was
very conscious about how islamic
upbringing especially performances of
prayers and you know when a person
performs their prayers and all sorts of
disciplines come into their life and i
was fortunate enough that my parents
guided me towards the studies of islam
so from a very young age I was in
Islamic seminary so I was God guarded
and protected from from the trials and
tribulations that most of the youth go
through in England having said that I
would come home on the weekends and I
would see my friends and people that I
grew up with associating and things or
you know engaging in activities that
were contrary today I'll bring me more
contrary to the Islamic faith and at
times it was a challenge because you'd
be invited towards those activities or
doing things and it's always been a
challenge and and that challenge will
never end because of the freedom
afforded to the youth and come in the
countries that we're living in so it's
like I'm to look you know more press or
loves protected from there i don't thing
anybody can be protected or saved unless
allah sadism and of course it starts
from home there's it has to be have a
strong structure in the house strong
Islamic system and also the community
plays a big role in the bringing of a
child and to provide in that environment
atmosphere where they could be securing
their Dean and they could practice Islam
securely now before we go into you give
us some advice for the people who want
to start a family have a family and
before that as I said the ship sails you
know we want to prepare it before the
children get out there in the real world
want to prepare them for the challenges
is like so at what point did you
consciously make a citizen because
people have to come you go from being a
young man a child to an adult and you
have to make a conscious decision to
submit to the crater that happens in
earth so at what point in your life will
get your father your parents are
teaching you is small but at what point
were you like
even some parents they teach them Islam
but they're like still they wander off
but others they stop and think and
they're like you know what what my
parents are teaching me really is the
truth it's based on proof evidences and
they even did wholeheartedly get into it
did you have that point in your life I
think that point came when I was a
closer to puberty and after completing
the Quran you know memorizing Quran not
understanding it but still wanting to
learn what the Quran actually means the
Shaitaan did attack me and shirt on told
me no you don't need to go to seminary
you might become proud and arrogant if
you become an Islamic scholar you might
shirt on tried many very many tricks and
many avenues that she had on a tax a
person especially a student of knowledge
is attacked greatly boat-shaped on so it
was it was a at that point that I
actually consulted my my teachers my
show you my advisors pick my mentors
whom you know I'm indebted to and I have
to pray for them a lot Allah blesses
them God blesses them for their efforts
and it was at that time that they guided
me you know this is this is the point
where you need to start reflecting and
realizing god favors upon you you know
lust chosen you for this path and you
have to remain on this path and stay on
it and stick to it so it was it was at
that point after memorizing the Quran
before enrolling economics in or close
to the age of puberty low for 13 14 when
I have that great transition or that
moment of my life way to make a decision
do I go back to school now after
completing hips of caught on a
memorization of Quran or do you now go
on to learn what the Quran means try and
apply in your lives and benefit others
it was at that point in my life that had
to really think about you know what what
direction I want to take a knife and you
know you know I never lost faithful and
never had and I never lost trust in what
my parents taught me I was knew this was
the truth and you know I was fortunate
enough that God guided me towards that
how important is it because we know
that's one of the verbatim word of God
is the Quran has been sent down for all
of mankind and it's a guidance of
healing for everybody so one of the
miracles is that we have it in
original memorized by millions but some
will memorize a Koran but how important
is it to memorize it but memorize it
with understanding how important is that
I think is extremely important because a
lot allah allah mentions not put on that
we revealed this book and it's blessed
so that you can reflect upon its
meanings you know in other parts of the
Quran Allah says God says and we made
this Quran easy for remembrance so how
does one take heat from it would say
lessons from derive a way of life or a
source of life from it unless they
understand it will truly reflects upon
its meanings I think it's extremely
important that when when the person
memorizes up what on he has to
understand or she has to understand this
is their path of life now God's chosen
them fall upon to be a true ambassador
Lippert on a hold of the Quran a
protector and preserve the Quran not
just preserving its literal words but
also preserving its meanings in actions
in in conveying its teachings in
teaching it to others so I think it's
extremely important that people
understand and that's why you will find
people that don't learn the meaning of
the port on after memorizing it they
don't have true value for the Quran you
will find unfortunately amongst those
that have memorized the Quran although
they are in esteemed position because
Allah selected them from his for his
words and for preserving his words they
don't tend to live the Islamic lifestyle
that's required from the person that has
learned to hold on now you've seen that
yes I have what advice do you have for
those who are inspiring to memorize the
Quran their parents maybe push them to
do it but they're dealing with this
dilemma now my advice to them is that
your journey doesn't end once you've
finished pulling all that would have
been asked the last chapter of the Quran
your journey has just begun because now
you have a responsibility and duty to
preserve the Quran in its true sense and
to convey its meanings to the people so
this is a path that Allah has chosen for
you and if you neglect this path and
your it's like you're neglecting the
fact that I last prepared for you and I
think it's a grave responsibility of
parents as well once you've chosen your
children for this path learning the
Quran preserving the Quran in its words
then they should allow them to excel and
to to learn Dean furthermore and not
just stop there has anyone asked you
let's say from our brothers and humanity
when you mention the crown and say well
how can I know that this is from the
Creator how do I know why do you guys
say this is a miracle sure what how
could people be confident that this is
from the Creator because the Quran is
unchanged unaltered unedited it's in the
original form of its revelation a lot on
Godfrey abilities to the Prophet
Muhammad and the source of its
revelation is known it's solid came from
God through Gabriel to Muhammad whereas
other scriptures the same cannot be said
of them the preservation of the Quran
rigorous efforts were made by earlier
Muslims to preserve its words and you
know this system of heavens and
memorization is one method that God
chose for its preservation so it's a
it's a very and nothing you'll find all
contradictions in the book you'll find
that it sits in the highest language
it's a miraculous words of miraculous
revealed at a time when people were
proud about their language took great
pride in that in the way they presented
a language skills and the Prophet
Muhammad being unlettered not knowing
how to read or write was conveying these
words sort of people with such with such
a fantasy and with such with such
strength and with such a thought
authority it there's no doubt in the
mind that this is word of God doesn't it
before to go to break doesn't the crater
that has an earth and Eric we say Allah
doesn't he identify himself that he's
the one that revealed that he's going to
protect it yes yes this is a guarantee
like stamp of approval this is that is
this is versatile Quran wakad says we
revealed the Quran as a remembrance and
we will protect it yeah it's a chat tell
me this one is it true that there's a
challenge in there someone says it's not
from God go ahead find one contradiction
yes exactly see in like other scriptures
yeah the Quran says I do they know did
they not reflect upon the Quran if it
was from other than on long they would
find many contradictions in the and the
Quran challenges people if this is the
word of man bring something like it
that's right that's what we're going to
be giving you the information on how you
can save your family it's going to be
from the verbatim word of god and the
teaching of the last and final message
center playing counter prob mohammed
we'll be right back with more so stay
tuned here
nisha it's like when did you think that
you had no purpose are you worthless the
value comes from purpose your purpose in
life is to worship the Creator no
worship your desires himself not worship
social pressure the celebrity culture
but worship the thing that's much higher
and transcendent above and beyond by
worshiping golden seeking his pleasure
you get pleased so you have double
pleasure back here on the Dean show or
Sheikh Yassin and we are humbly trying
to really relate to the people out there
you know the message the beauty of the
purpose of life that's from the Creator
it's not organized religion organized by
man or men it's indeed a way of life a
system that's for all mankind and even
in here it tells you how to raise your
family how to bring up righteous
children so you have memorized this book
we talked about it being a miracle so
the person now that got to hear khurram
miracle from crater might continue to
listen and you've also you went through
those pressures you know have some
experience so what advice do you give
for parents before the time comes and he
comes knocking on your door because
you're the Imam and they come knocking
at door hey my son has joined the gang
hey my son he just smacked me upside the
head my son's currently using ze I
didn't teach him French but he's you
know these speaking French you know what
kind of French I'm staying right so
before it comes to that what advice do
you give the parents things it's
important for parents to reflect once
they make this decision of having kids
and bringing kids into this world
children into this world what their
responsibilities is as parents now we
have we have rights and the children
have rights upon us and we have duties
that we have to fulfill related to the
physical operating of a child and we're
all aware of that Muslim non-muslim it
doesn't matter everybody's fulfilling
that right of the child raising them
nurturing them nourishing them you know
when it comes to nutrition and giving
them rest and giving them a home and
giving them closer where but when it
comes to the direction in life that they
need to lead the spirituality of the
child nurturing that molding them on it
on a way of life that's where many
people fail so it's really important
that parents change their direction in
life before they start to bring children
is it as well because having children is
a great responsibility and Duty for any
person it's not and it's not just the
physical responsibilities of the child
that way account accountable for we're
in front of a lot we are shepherds we
have to lead our flock towards the right
direction and that destination is gender
and a las perras pleasure so it's
important that we make this conscious
decision to choose the right way of life
before we bring to your children's as
well and once we do we have to we have
to bring Islam into our lives
wholeheartedly not this pick and choose
Islam that we're living by in present
time not a buffet exactly it's not about
female where you can go I like buffets
by the way to interfere eat all you want
you know that's what you know that's a
Texan way I think it's a lot of related
a lot under the right place and so going
going back to the question you notice we
choose and pick and choose what we want
to follow and unless a is regarding the
people before Muslims before Islam they
used to say we believe in the in some of
it and will reject some of it not going
to be Bart learn that foot will be wrong
and we don't want to live that sort of
lifestyle haces enter Islam fully so
when we bring children this is well we
have to realize we can't have this pick
and choose a slump we can't be a
hypocritical in our in our perception of
Dean otherwise if we'd got our
children's or something and we're not
practicing ourselves they would never
have will never have an effect on our
children therefore I think that parents
need to be role models number one they
need to have the right direction roof in
their own lives after they have adopted
those qualities and they have a very
strong structure in their own lives and
they molded around their lives are
molded around Dean children will pick up
from that instantly you know if that
your day starts with prejudice Allah you
know if your day ends with Asia and if
your if your if your structure around
the house is modeled around the prayers
timings if you go out to the more you go
out to grocery shopping but you're
conscious about prayer timings and this
is just one one example of the prayers
itself and then speaking about a lot on
the dinner
we're speaking about online everywhere
you go you go into the car with your
child he speaks about Allah he asked him
about a las proud of you know like local
man in the Quran when he speaks to his
son and he says to him that if there was
a mustard seed hidden somewhere who
would bring it who would know about it
only Allah would know about it o son
perform your prayers enjoying good
forbid evil be patient and he's advising
his son all of these different advices
about his character do not be do not be
haughty not me proud do not be very good
do not both so this conversation has to
take place it's a it's a question of
impressions in our children they're on
online most of the time they go to
schools 40 hours a week in the
Constitution's they go everywhere and
whatever they see around them their
impression and they're impressionable
and if we're not having these
conversations with our children we're
not speaking to them about a lot about
chastity morality you know the values
that we want to instill in them as
Muslims then somebody else is having
that conversation with them somebody
else is taking that precious time away
from us today unfortunately we're not
spending enough time with our children
and time is a huge factor how many times
do we do we go out without daughters as
fathers you know how many fathers take
their daughters out and say you know for
a day out on a Saturday she's looking
for that when she's a teenage girl she's
looking for a father somebody a male
figure to take her out and teach you how
a woman should be treated you know to
give her some quality time to ask her
how her day has been who are her friends
what does she like in life what are the
things that she likes will have dislikes
how many fathers know that about their
daughters how many sons not how many
fathers know that about their sons you
know they shouldn't be living in fear of
their parents they should be some
respect and parents need to be
appearance and more same period seems to
be friends but they have to have these
conversations with their children they
have to talk to them all the time
constantly reminding not impose not
force from a very young age talk to them
about Allah talk to them about their
direction life talking about morality
about chastity about the Prophet
Muhammad's Eliza read stories with them
die leaving the house I think is so
important it for the structure of a
Muslim household five minutes a day is
extremely effective read the book hiatus
to have our stories of the Sahaba read a
book the other side ahead gardens of the
pious and just read from there too
we I had these everyday narrations of
the prophet mohamed salah salem relate
to them stories from the quran about the
prophets talk to him and how they have
these conversations of them and you'll
find they'll be impression by the state
would have a great impression of its not
and inshallah it will lead to a strong
structure in the household inshallah
also the community plays a huge role in
this and one of the differences I find
between us and UK and I don't this isn't
question on I even ask this question but
I think one of the main differences i
found was that in England there was a
strong educational structure for for all
muslim kids all muslim kids in UK
growing up ninety percent of them i
would say enroll at a local masjid after
school five to seven on the daily basis
during school year and in fact even
summer holidays we were in and out of
and they went there they learn on of
course but they also learn islam they
learn up get up they don't feel they
learn hadith narration probably learnt
see it on the biography of the Prophet
Muhammad and it was a structure if every
child went through whereas in the US we
don't have this structure we have sunday
school even that is some places it's
strong some places this week many
children are lost many children models
so we're we almost got to go to break so
ensure i'm gonna ask you some more
questions i have a lot more to ask you
but you know it's sad that the time is
always short so if you can try to get
everything out that i throw at you to
the people and the next question i don't
know how important is it that we teach
our family the pure way of life the pure
way of life that was sent from the
Creator i know we love our culture and
our customs from back home but now we
brought our families here to America and
now we're teaching back home culture and
now how much of it where's the thin line
that we don't cross because at the end
of children like and my parents been
teaching me seventy percent culture and
a 24-percent Islam or whatnot friends
i'll give you just one example for
instance we know that the dowry that's
for the what the miguel the girl but you
it's sad to say some people are taking a
cost a custom and they do it for the
work for the for the man right so these
are customs and cultures that conflict
now with Islam where's the borden how do
we know you know so we don't Oh
well the kids and at the end you know
Islam is something that changes a person
for the better it's the best self
defense from gambling from alcohol from
all the evil vices so how do we make
sure we're doing it God's Way not our
desires I think education is really
important i think many people that come
from from other countries and they
settle in this country and they choose
to raise a family here they themselves
are unaware uneducated in islamic
matters and they they are you know they
practice cultural and they're not
they'll be unaware that the cultural
practices that they had here to have no
basis in islam i think education starts
from the parents and of course the
masjid that imam they show you the
scholars they have a leading role to
play in this where they have that you
know they have the platform the member
the pulpit on the weekly basis
addressing thousands of people to
address some of these challenging issues
where many people need to be educated on
the on the status of women in islam the
status of women and status of you finish
la mia something so many different
cultural problems that we're having or
we're facing need to be addressed on
from the message from the from the
pulpit if the parents themselves are
uneducated on these matters then it's
very hard for them to teach puri salam
to their children good to know your Dean
exactly get to know what your Creator
yes what he wants from you that is the
key right there and you know some people
say look I lost a pro right what was a
real son I gotta get the PhD so do we
get things ok get there but get the
knowledge of the Dean first knowledge of
the Dean is accentuates for the hair off
them ya know you can you can educate
well do masses which is your
responsibility but we were going to die
one day and the reality is we're going
to face our crazy on our Muslim if we
don't know I would be then you know
we're setting ourselves up for failure
all the degrees are going to help them
right now we'll take a break rather more
here on the D show you think these
things are going to bring you happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction
it's going to end up causing you if it
hasn't already a lot of pain think
you're happy you're kidding you're
sitting is really all what we are
offering in Islam what we have found in
Islam for ourselves is a means by which
our hearts are in peace they're at rest
they're not discontent we are pleased
with what we have
I am not afraid I'm not afraid and alone
I am not afraid I'm not afraid to stand
alone I am Not Afraid back here on the
Dean show or shake y'all seen now let's
talk to the to the youth now the parents
we talked about them doing their role
connecting them with the Creator
educating them spending family time
quality time how about for the youth now
that kind of they haven't had that
they're tuning in the friends have
turned their life around and they're
trying to call their friends to goodness
that's it and watching the show but they
don't think it's cool to be a Muslim
they don't if they think it's more cool
to quote lady gaga's that according the
prophet you know how already got to say
to them well it doesn't take a scientist
or rocket scientist to figure out that
way of life is is is destructive we look
at celebrity lifestyles today you don't
find any happiness in any of their in
their lives and then you find Whitney
Houston just committed well overdose and
Lindsey loans and in rehab Britney
Spears was in rehab so with this is what
we know about celebrity lifestyles and
there's no happiness there's no that
sort of line so it destructive when
there's no God in your life when there's
not one fizzle not healing your life
there is no purpose sense of purpose in
your life what are you working for what
are you living for so my message to the
youth that wants to aspire towards
that's all lifestyle and they think the
Islamic lifestyle is on call how long is
it call forward to be cool
quote unquote when you're going to age
one day we're all going to age him in
today somebody told me I'm an on-call
because now have three kids I'm only 30
and I don't feel like an uncle then
we're going to age and we aspire to the
wrong things from now and we don't we're
setting ourselves up for failure later
on so my message to the youth is a
choose a role model whose way of life is
is fulfilling its satisfactory why are
we finding so many people flocking to
the religion of Islam why are people
finding eternal peace in the religion of
Islam why are people finding eternal
peace in this one no problem hammer
salah salem why are we not studying
Islam deeply why when it look while
we're not looking into this lifestyle
rather than being influenced by by the
things by / pressured by other things so
I would advise a youth to study to read
to connect with their local message so
the bottarga muslim youth and look into
that lifestyle and and and read the
merits of this and they'll find peace
and tranquility in their lives def is a
reality step and after death the day of
judgment reality Hellfires a reality
paradise and these things are a reality
that we're going to have to what we do
in this life will be accountable so at
the end Hellfire paradises is what all
the messages in car talk yes so we got
to get it right now exactly definitely
it's a reality and the discussion of
hell and heaven it's as old as the
discussion as old as the creation of man
as soon as long as man has been in this
world the discussion of heaven and hell
took place it's a reality is undeniable
nobody can reject it therefore we have
to practice and adhere to the teaching
that will take us with paradise refrain
from the Hellfire last closing comments
and suggestions a one broke briefly that
woman left to the parents or struggling
with their children and the children who
are really you know having a hard time
growing up here you know so much
temptation so many things just suck in
dari mana way they caught up in all the
different things of the tantalize a
shins of his life and I having a hard
time is submit
what do you got a sec well it's it
appearance my message is that if you you
know continue trying make dua
supplication our last panel data to God
to help you in this path raising
children everybody needs to help of God
nobody can do it without the help of
gotten the guidance of God and God
guides he wishes nobody can guide whom
sight of God wishes to misguide but the
effort has to start from home we have to
be very strong in our efforts and we
have to be very wise and use tax and
wisdom that's very important for the
parents my message to the youth is that
do not succumb to the pressures in
society do not keep up with the Joneses
that's not what we're here for we have
we're here to follow the prompts to
lighten up we've given a pure pure way
of life study its read about it learn it
and try and adopt it thank you very much
I got away the clever words please be
empty salami and thank you for tuning in
to another episode on the Dean show no
time lost when you're sitting and you're
learning something that can benefit your
life when you're hearing the good advice
you're putting off all the hip-hop mute
music and the rock music and all the
other things up there there are no
benefit when you sit and you take time
to reflect over the creation of the
heavens and earth what's my purpose of
life where am I going when I die and
you're beseeching the help of the crater
that happens in her because you can't do
it on your own is one God he sent
messengers to guide us but how you going
to know what the guidance is if you
don't ask the crater for the guidance
and I'm just going to share before we
end because we're here in Dallas all one
of my teachers is here and he shared
something real beautiful me that just
stuck with me so I was listening to him
to a person a knowledge and it stuck
with me it was something good hopefully
you could benefit from his good he told
me that we need to work hard in this
life fill in our grave with good deeds
before we visit the grape because we're
all going to visit that place and we
need to work to please hard are created
before we meet our Creator and we need
to work hard to disallow from this life
before this life says bye-bye to us and
that is great advice that we can all
benefit from because we're going to be
leaving this life is transitory and the
hereafter is forever Hellfires real
paradise is for real and we want to
shoot high and as for Jenna so let's
work hard to please our Creator before
death overtakes us and if you have any
further questions as visit us at
d show calm every week and call us 1 866
to Islam operators are standing by to
ask us your questions or even if you
want to accept the way of life that
Jesus Moses Abraham all the messages is
God live they all submit it to god they
worship the crater not the creation you
could do it too call us we'll see you
next time peace be unto you
you